le pouvoir est dans une sorte d'impasse
parce que il ne sait pas comment
discuter avec une partie de la société
alors évidemment il ya l'argument que
c'est ces gens sont tous manipulés de
l'étranger mais personne n'y croit qui
est des manipulateurs qui est des
interventions de tel ou tel
on appelle ça de soual soft power soit
les agences évidemment qu'ils sont les
agences étrangères les allemands les par
les alpha les allemands les américains
sont intéressés pour suivre et
éventuellement déstabiliser en fait un
concurrent qui quand même bien affaibli
mais c'est pas accès quand c'est pas ça
qui est personne n'y croit parce que
c'est bien clair que on a là des
problèmes intérieurs préoccupant est que
pour l'instant le pouvoir ne sait pas
répondre autrement que par des mesures
législatives de plus en plus
contraignantes dans tout un tas de
domaines je pense qu'on va y revenir
il y là il ya un nombre de lots a
extraordinairement autoritaire et qui en
renforce les la surveillance de la
société et de toute opposition qui ont
été votées fin décembre dans les
derniers jours de décembre 2020 tout à
fait étonnante et d'autre part cette
répression
d'ailleurs refusé toute autorisation de
manifestation il ya il ya des experts
russes que je viens de j'ai lu ça
aujourd'hui qu'ils disent mais enfin si
on avait autorisé cette manifestation il
y aurait eu quelques dizaines de
milliers de manifestants ils se seraient
ils auraient eu froid ils seraient
restés sur place et puis seraient
dispersés et probablement on en aurait
moins parler alors peut-être que c'est
un point de vue un peu naïf mais enfin
voilà pour l'instant ce que je constate
c'est que le pouvoir actuel ne sais pas
comment parler avec une partie de la
population qui une partie jeunes actives
assez déterminé parce que pour sortir
manifester dans ces conditions il faut
être très déterminé et et à terme cela
risque de poser quand même des problèmes
importants
oui
[Musique]